invertir en el gas natural licuado para
reducir la dependencia del gas ruso en
cualquier caso esta es una de las
opciones que está considerando alemania
este sábado el ministro de economía
alemán robert huff visitó qatar uno de
los tres mayores exportadores de gas
natural licuado unos días antes el
ministro ecologista también había
visitado noruega el objetivo de alemania
es evitar la escasez de gas el próximo
invierno bertrand sanguinetti alemán ya
está cambiando su estrategia energética
y su dependencia del gas ruso noruega es
uno de los principales proveedores de
gas al continente europeo hemos hablado
de las capacidades de las plantas de gas
licuado que se están construyendo en
alemania
desde hace varios días el gobierno está
multiplicando las iniciativas para
sustituir el suministro de gas ruso
puesto bajo revisión por la guerra de
ucrania la energía se ha convertido en
una cuestión central para los países
europeos la mayoría de ellos dependen
del gas y el petróleo rusos el tema es
especialmente sensible para alemania el
55 por ciento de sus importaciones de
gas proceden directamente y además su
decisión en 2012 de cerrar sus centrales
atómicas le ha empujado a invertir en
energías renovables pero también a
persistir en su dependencia del gas ruso
para hacer frente a la situación cada
país europeo tiene su propio método
junto con noruega berlín también
estudiará la posibilidad de importar
hidrógeno verde bélgica al igual que
otros países confía más en la energía
nuclear por el aumento de los precios de
la energía el país acaba de anunciar su
decisión de aplazar 10 años la salida
del esquema nuclear previsto
inicialmente para 2025 desde el comienzo
de la invasión rusa en ucrania el precio
del combustible ha ido subiendo de forma
constante en toda europa